PATRICK WINSTON: So
where are we?
We started off with simple
methods for learning stuff.
Then, we talked a little about
a purchase of learning that
we're vaguely inspired by.
The fact that our heads are
stuffed with neurons, and that
we seemed to have evolved
from primates.
Then, we talked about looking at
the problem and address the
issue of [? phrenology ?]
and how it's possible
to learn concepts.
But now, we're coming full
circle back to the beginning
and thinking about how to
divide up a space with
decision boundaries.
But whereas, you do it with
a neural net or a nearest
neighbors or a ID tree.
Those are very simple ideas
that work very often.
Today, we're going to talk about
a very sophisticated
idea that still has
a implementation.
So this needs to be
in the tool bag of
every civilized person.
This is about support
vector machines, an
idea that was developed.
Well, I want to talk to
you today about how
ideas develop, actually.
Because you look at stuff like
this in a book, and you think,
well, Vladimir Vapnik just
figured this out one Saturday
afternoon when the weather was
too bad to go outside.
That's not how it happens.
It happens very differently.
I want to talk to you
a little about that.
The next thing about great
things that were done by
people who are still alive
is you can ask them
how they did it.
You can't do that
with Fourier.
You can't say to Fourier,
how did you do it?
Did you dream it up on
a Saturday afternoon?
But can call Vapnik on the phone
and ask him questions.
That's the stuff I'm going
to talk about toward
the end of the hour.
Well, it's all about decision
boundaries.
And now, we have several
techniques that we can use to
draw some decision boundaries.
And here's the same problem.
And if we drew decision
boundaries in here, we might
get something that would
look like maybe this.
If we were doing a nearest
neighbor approach, and if
we're doing ID trees, we'll just
draw in a line like that.
And if we're doing neural nets,
well, you can put in a
lot of straight lines wherever
you like with a neural net,
depending on how it's
trained up.
Or if you just simply go in
there and design it, so you
could do that if you wanted.
And you would think that after
people have been working on
this sort of stuff for 50 or 75
years that there wouldn't
be any tricks in the bag left.
And that's when everybody got
surprised, because around the
early '90s Vladimir Vapnik
introduced the ideas I'm about
to talk to you about.
So what Vapnik says is
something like this.
Here you have a space, and you
have some negative examples,
and you have some positive
examples.
How do you divide the positive
examples from
the negative examples?
And what he says that we want
to do is we want to draw a
straight line.
But which straight line
is the question.
Well, we want to draw
a straight line.
Well, would this be a
good straight line?
One that went up like that?
Probably not so hot.
How about one that's
just right here?
Well, that might separate them,
but it seems awfully
close to the negative
examples.
So maybe what we ought to do
is we ought to draw our
straight line in here,
sort of like this.
And that line is drawn with a
view toward putting in the
widest street that separates the
positive samples from the
negative samples.
That's why I call it the
widest street approach.
So that makes way of putting
in the decision boundary--
is to put in a straight line but
in contrast with the way
ID tree puts in a
straight line.
It tries to put the line in in
such a way as the separation
between the positive and
negative examples.
That street is as wide
as possible.
All right.
So you might think to do that in
the UROP project, and then,
let it go with that.
What's the big deal?
So what we've got to do is we've
got to go through why
it's a big deal.
So first of all, we like to
think about how you would make
a decision rule that would use
that decision boundary.
So what I'm going to ask you to
imagine is that we've got a
vector of any length that you
like, constrained to be
perpendicular to the median, or
if you like, perpendicular
to the gutters.
It's perpendicular to the median
line of the street.
All right, it's drawn in such
a way that that's true.
We don't know anything about
it's length, yet.
Then, we also have some unknown,
say, right here.
And we have a vector that
points to it by excel.
So now, what we're really
interested in is whether or
not that unknown is on the right
side of the street or on
the left side of the street.
So what we'd what to do is want
to project that vector,
u, down on to one that's
perpendicular to the street.
Because then, we'll have the
distance in this direction or
a number that's proportional
to this in this direction.
And the further out we go, the
closer we'll get to being on
the right side of the street,
where the right side of the
street is not the correct side
but actually the right side of
the street.
So what we can do is we can say,
let's take w and dot it
with u and measure whether or
not that number is equal to or
greater than some constant, c.
So remember that the dot
product has taken the
projection onto w.
And the bigger that projection
is, the further out along this
line the projection will lie.
And eventually it will be so
big that the projection
crosses the median line of the
street, and we'll say it must
be a positive sample.
Or we could say, without loss
of generality that the dot
product plus some constant, b,
is equal to or greater than 0.
If that's true, then it's
a positive sample.
So that's our decision rule.
And this is the first in several
elements that we're
going to have to line up to
understand this idea called
support vector machines.
So that's the decision rule.
And the trouble is we don't know
what constant to use, and
we don't know which
w to use either.
We know that w has to be
perpendicular to the median
line of the street.
But there's lot of w's that
are perpendicular to the
median line of the street,
because it
could be of any length.
So we don't have enough
constraint here to fix a
particular b or a
particular w.
Are you with me so far?
All right.
And this, by the way, we get
just by saying that c
equals minus b.
What we're going to do next is
we're going to lay on some
additional constraints whether
you're toward putting enough
constraint on the situation that
we can actually calculate
a b and a w.
So what we're going to say is
this, that if we look at this
quantity that we're checking out
to be greater than or less
than 0 to make our decision,
then, what we're going to do
is we're going to say that if we
take that vector w, and we
take the dot product of that
with some x plus, some
positive sample, now.
This is not an unknown.
This is a positive sample.
If we take the dot product of
those two vectors, and we had
b just like in our decision
rule, we're going to want that
to be equal to or
greater than 1.
So in other words, you can be
an unknown anywhere in this
street and be just a little bit
greater or just a little
bit less than 0.
But if you're a positive sample,
we're going to insist
that this decision function
gives the
value of one or greater.
Likewise, if w thought it was
some negative sample is
provided to us, then we're going
to say that has to be
equal to or less than minus 1.
All right.
So if you're a minus sample,
like one of these two guys or
any minus sample that may lie
down here, this function that
gives us the decision rule must
return minus 1 or less.
So there's a separation
of distance here.
Minus 1 to plus 1 for
all of the samples.
So that's cool.
But we're not quite done,
because carrying around two
equations like this,
it's a pain.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to introduce
another variable to make
like a little easier.
Like many things that we do, and
when we develop this kind
of stuff, introducing this
variable is not something that
God says has to be done.
What is it?
We introduced this additional
stuff to do what?
To make the mathematics more
convenient, so mathematical
convenience.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to introduce a
variable, y sub i, such that y
sub i is equal to plus 1 for
plus samples and minus 1
for negative samples.
All right.
So for each sample, we're going
to have a value for this
new quantity we've
introduced, y.
And the value of y is going to
be determined by whether it's
a positive sample or
negative sample.
If it's a positive sample it's
got to be plus 1 for this
situation up here, and it's
going to be minus 1 for this
situation down here.
So what we're going to do with
this first equation is we're
going to multiply it by y sub
i, and that is now x of i,
plus b is equal to or
greater than 1.
And then, you know what
we're going to do?
We're going to multiply the left
side of this equation by
y sub i, as well.
So the second equation becomes
y sub i times x sub i plus b.
And now, what does that
do over here?
We multiplied this guy
times minus 1.
So it used to be the case that
that was less than minus 1.
So if we multiply it by minus
1, then it has to be greater
than plus 1.
The two equations are the same,
because that introduces
this little mathematical
convenience.
So now, we can say that y sub
i times x sub i plus b.
Well, what we're going to do--
Brett?
STUDENT: What happened
to the w?
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh, did
I leave out a w?
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Yeah, I wouldn't have gotten
very far with that.
So that's dot it with
w, dot it with w.
Thank you, Brett.
Those are all vectors.
I'll pretty soon forget to put
the little vector marks on
there, but you know
what I mean.
So that's w plus b.
And now, let me bring that 1
over to the left side, and
that's equal to or
greater than 0.
All right.
With Brett's correction, I
think everything's OK.
But we're going to take one more
step, and we're going to
say that y sub i times x sub
i times w plus b minus 1.
It's always got to be equal
to or greater than 0.
But what I'm going to
say is if we're for
x sub i in a gutter.
So there's always going to be
greater than 0, but we're
going to add the additional
constraint that it's going to
be exactly 0 for all the samples
that end up in the
gutters here of the street.
So the value of that expression
is going to be
exactly 0 for that sample, 0
for this sample and this
sample, not 0 for that sample.
It's got to be greater than 1.
All right?
So that's step number two.
And this is step number one.
OK.
So now, we've just got some
expressions to talk about,
some constraints.
Now, what are we trying
to do here?
I forgot.
Oh, I remember now.
We're trying to figure out how
to arrange for the line to be
such at the street separating
the pluses from the minuses as
wide as possible.
So maybe we better figure out
how we can express the
distance between the
two gutters.
Let's just repeat our drawing.
We've got some minuses here, got
pluses out here, and we've
got gutters that are
going down here.
And now, we've got a vector here
to a minus, and we've got
a vector here to a plus.
So we'll call that x plus
and this x minus.
So what's the width
of the street?
I don't know, yet.
But what we can do is we can
take the difference of those
two vectors, and that will
be a vector that
looks like this, right?
So that's x plus
minus x minus.
So now, if I only had a unit
normal that's normal to the
median line of the street, if
it's a unit normal, then I
could just take the dot product
or that unit normal
and this difference vector, and
that would be the width of
the street, right?
So in other words, if I had a
unit vector in that direction,
then I could just dot the two
together, and that would be
the width of the street.
So let me write that down
before I forget.
So the width is equal to
x plus minus x minus.
OK.
That's the difference vector.
And now, I've got to multiple
it by unit vector.
But wait a minute.
I said that that w is
a normal, right?
The w is a normal.
So what I can do is I can
multiply this times w, and
then, we'll divide by the
magnitude of w, and that will
make it a unit vector.
So that dot product, not a
product, that dot product is,
in fact, a scalar, and it's
the width of the street.
It doesn't do as much good,
because it doesn't look like
we get much out of it.
Oh, but I don't know.
Let's see, what can
we get out of it?
Oh gee, we've got this equation
over here, this
equation that constrains
the samples
that lie in the gutter.
So if we have a positive sample,
for example, then this
is plus 1, and we have
this equation.
So it says that x plus times w
is equal to, oh, 1 minus b.
See, I'm just taking this part
here, this vector here, and
I'm dotting it with x plus.
So that's this piece
right here.
y is 1 for this kind
of sample.
So I'll just take the 1 and the
b back over to the other
side, and I've got 1 minus b.
OK?
Well, we can do the same
trick with x minus.
If we've got a negative sample,
then y sub i is negative.
That gives us our negative
w times dot over x sub i.
But now, we take this stuff back
over to the right side,
and we get 1 plus b.
So that all licenses to rewrite
this thing as 2 over
the magnitude of w.
How did I get there?
Well, I decided I was going to
enforce this constraint.
I noted that the width of the
street has got to be this
difference vector times
a unit vector.
Then, I used the constraint to
plug back some values here.
And I discovered to my delight
and amazement that the width
of the street is 2 over
the magnitude of w.
Yes, Brett?
STUDENT: So your first x
plus is minus b, and x
minus is 1 plus b.
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah.
STUDENT: So you're
subtracting it?
PATRICK WINSTON: Let's see.
If I've got a minus here, then
that makes that minus, and
then, the b is minus, and when I
take the b over to the other
side it becomes plus.
STUDENT: Yeah, so if you
subtract the left with the
right [INAUDIBLE].
PATRICK WINSTON: No.
No, sorry.
This expression here
is 1 plus b.
Trust me it works.
I haven't got my legs all
tangled up like last Friday,
well, not yet, anyway.
It's possible.
There's going to be a lot of
algebra here eventually.
So this quantity here, this
is miracle number three.
This quantity here is the
width of the street.
And what we're trying to
do is we're trying to
maximize that, right?
So we want to maximize 2 over
the magnitude of w if we're to
get the widest street under
the constraints that we've
decided that we're going
to work with.
All right.
So that means that it's OK to
maximize 1 over w, instead.
We just drop the constant.
And that means that it's
OK to minimize the
magnitude of w, right?
And that means that it's OK
to minimize 1/2 times the
magnitude of w squared.
Right, Brett?
Why did I do that?
Why did I multiply by
1/2 and square it?
STUDENT: Because it's
mathematically convenient.
PATRICK WINSTON: It's
Thank you.
So this is point number three
in the development.
So where do we go?
We decided that was going
to be our decision rule.
We're going to see which side
of the line we're on.
We decided to constrain the
situation, so the value of the
decision rule is plus 1 in the
gutters for the positive
samples and minus 1
in the gutters for
the negative samples.
And then, we discovered that
maximizing the width of the
street led us to an expression
like that,
which we wish to maximize.
Should we take a break?
Should we get coffee?
Too bad, we can't do that in
this kind of situation.
But we would if we could.
And I'm sure when Vapnik
got to this point, he
went out for coffee.
So now, we back up, and we say,
well, let's let these
expressions start developing
into a song.
Not like that, that's vapid,
speaking of Vapnik.
What song is it going to sing?
We've got an expression here
that we'd like to find the
minimum of, the extremum of.
And we've got some constraints
here that we
would like to honor.
What are we going to do?
Let me put what we're going
to do to you in
the form of a puzzle.
Is it got something to
do with Legendre?
Has it got something
to do with Laplace?
Or does it have something
to do with Lagrange?
She says Lagrange.
Actually, all three were said
to be on Fourier's Doctoral
Defense Committee-- must have
been quite an example.
But we want to talk about
Lagrange, because we've got a
situation here.
Is this 1801?
1802?
1802.
We learned in 1802 that if we
going to find the extremum of
a function with constraints,
then we're going to have to
use Lagrange multipliers.
That would give us a new
expression, which we can
maximize or minimize without
thinking about
the constraints anymore.
That's how Lagrange
multipliers work.
So this brings us to miracle
number four, developmental
piece number four.
And it works like this.
We're going to say that L--
the thing we're going to try
to maximize in order to
maximize the width
of the street--
is equal to 1/2 times the
magnitude of that vector, w,
squared minus.
And now, we've got to have
a summation over all the
constraints.
And each or those constraints is
going to have a multiplier,
alpha sub i.
And then, we write down
the constraint.
And when we write down
a constraint,
there it is up there.
And I've got to be hyper
careful here, because,
otherwise, I'll get lost
in the algebra.
So the constraint is y sub i
times vector, w, dotted with
vector x sub i plus b, and
now, I've got a closing
parenthesis, a minus 1.
That's the end of my constraint,
like so.
I sure hope I've got that right,
because I'll be in deep
trouble if that's wrong.
Anybody see any bugs in that?
That looks right. doesn't it?
We've got the original thing
we're trying to work with.
Now, we've got Lagrange
multipliers all multiplied.
It's back to that constraint
up there, where each
constraint is constrained
to be 0.
Well, there's a little bit of
mathematical slight of hand
here, because in the end, the
ones that are going to be 0,
the Lagrange multipliers here.
The ones that are going to be
non 0 are going to be the ones
connected with vectors that
lie in the gutter.
The rest are going to be 0.
But in any event, we can pretend
that this is what
we're doing.
I don't care whether it's
a maximum or minimum.
I've lost track.
But what we're going to do is
we're going to try to find an
extremum of that.
So what do we do?
What does 1801 teach us about?
Finding the maximum--
well, we've got to find the
derivatives and set them to 0.
And then, after we've done that,
a little bit of that
manipulation, we're going
to see a wonderful
song start to emerge.
So let's see if we can do it.
Let's take the partial of L, the
Lagrangian, with respect
to the vector, w.
Oh my God, how do you
differentiate with
respect to a vector?
It turns out that it has a form
that looks exactly like
differentiating with respect
to a scalar.
And the way you prove that to
yourself is you just expand
everything in terms of all of
the vector's components.
You differentiate those with
respect to what you're
differentiating with respect
to, and everything
turns out the same.
So what you get when you
differentiate this with
respect to the vector, w, is 2
comes down, and we have just
magnitude of w.
Was it the magnitude of w?
Yeah, like so.
Oh, it's not the
magnitude of w.
It's just w, like so, no
magnitude involved.
Then, we've got a w over here,
so we've got to differentiate
this part with respect
to w, as well.
But that part's a lot easier,
because all we
have there is a w.
There's no magnitude.
It's not raised to any power.
So what's w multiplied by?
Well, it's multiplied by x and
y sub i and alpha sub i.
All right.
So that means that this
expression, this derivative of
the Lagrangian, with respect to
w is going to be equal to w
minus the sum of alpha sub i,
y sub i, x sub i, and that's
got to be set to 0.
And that implies that w is equal
to the sum of some alpha
i, some scalars, times this
minus 1 or plus 1 variable
times x sub i over i.
And now, the math is
beginning to sing.
Because it tells us that the
vector w is a linear sum of
the samples, all the samples
or some of the sample.
It didn't have to be that way.
It could have been raised
to a power.
It could have been
a logarithm.
All sorts of horrible
things could have
happened when we did this.
But when we did this, we
discovered that w is going to
be equal to a linear some
of these vectors here.
Some of the vectors in the
sample set, and I say some,
because for some alpha
will be 0.
All right.
So this is something that we
want to take note of as
something important.
Now, of course, we've got to
differentiate L with respect
to anything else it might
vary, so we've got to
differentiate L with respect
to b, as well.
So what's that going
to be equal to?
Well, there's no b in here, so
that makes no contribution.
This part here doesn't have a
b in it, so that makes no
contribution.
There's no b over here, so that
makes no contribution.
So we've got alpha i times
y sub i times b.
That has a contribution.
So that's going to be the sum
of alpha i times y sub i.
And then, we're differentiating
with respect
to b, so that disappears.
There's a minus sign here, and
that's equal to 0, or that
implies that the sum of the
alpha i times y sub
i is equal to 0.
Hm, that looks like that might
be helpful somewhere.
And now, it's time
for more coffee.
By the way, these coffee
periods take months.
You stare at it.
You work on something else.
You've got to worry
about your finals.
And you think about
it some more.
And eventually, you come
back from coffee
and do the next thing.
Oh, what is the next thing?
Well, we've still got this
expression that we're trying
to find the minimum for.
And you say to yourself, this
is really a job for the
numerical analysts.
Those guys know about
this sort of stuff.
Because of that little power
in there, that square.
This is a so-called quadratic
optimization problem.
So at this point, you would be
inclined to hand this problem
over to a numerical analysts.
They'll come back in a few
weeks with an algorithm.
You implement the algorithm.
And maybe things work.
Maybe they don't converge.
But any case, you don't
worry about it.
But we're not going to do that,
because we want to do a
little bit more math, because
we're interested
in stuff like this.
We're interested in the fact
that the decision vector is a
linear sum of the samples.
So we're going to work a little
harder on this stuff.
And in particular, now that
we've got an expression for w,
this one right here, we're
going to plug it back in
there, and we're going to plug
it back in here and see what
happens to that thing
we're trying to find
the extremum of.
Is everybody relaxed,
taking deep breath?
Actually, this is the
easiest part.
This is just doing a little
bit of the algebra.
So the think we're trying
to maximize or
minimize is equal to 1/2.
And now, we've got to
have this vector
here in there twice.
Right?
Because we're multiplying
the two together.
So let's see.
We've got from that expression
up there, one of those w's
will just be the sum of the
alpha i times y sub i times
the vector x sub i.
And then, we've got the
other one, too.
So that's just going to
be the sum of alpha.
Now, I'm going to, actually,
eventually, squish those two
sums together into a double
summation, so I have to keep
the indexes straight.
So I'm just going to write
that as alpha sub j, y
sub j, x sub j.
So those are my two vectors and
I'm going to take the dot
product of those.
That's the first piece, right?
Boy, this is hard.
So minus, and now, the next term
looks like alpha i, y sub
i, x sub i times w.
So you've got a whole
bunch of these.
We've got a sum of alpha i times
y sub i times x sub i,
and then, that gets multiplied
times w.
So we'll put this like this, the
sum of alpha j, y sub j, x
sub j in there like that.
And then, that's the dot
product like that.
That wasn't as bad
as I thought.
Now, I've got to deal with the
next term, the alpha i times y
sub i times b.
So that's minus sub of alpha
i times y sub i times b.
And then, to finish it off, we
have plus the sum of alpha sub
i minus 1 up there, minus 1 in
front of the summation, such
as the sum of the alphas.
Are you with me so far?
Just a little algebra.
It looks good.
I think I haven't
mucked it, yet.
Let's see.
alpha i times y sub i times
b. b is a constant.
So pull that out there, and
then, I just got the sum of
alpha sub i times y sub i.
Oh, that's good.
That's 0.
Now, so for every one of these
terms, we dot it with this
whole expression.
So that's just like taking this
thing here and dotting
those two things together,
right?
Oh, but that's just the same
thing we've got here.
So now, what we can do is we
can say that we can rewrite
this Lagrangian as--
we've got that sum of alpha i.
That's the positive element.
And then, we've got one of
these and half of these.
So that's minus 1/2.
And now, I'll just convert that
whole works into a double
sum over both i and j of alpha
i times alpha j times y sub i
times y sub j times x sub
i dotted with x of j.
We sure went through a lot of
trouble to get there, but now,
we've got it.
And we know that what we're
trying to do is we're trying
to find a maximum of
that expression.
And that's the one we're
going to had off to
the numerical analysts.
So if we're going to had this
off to the numerical analysts
anyway, why did I go to
all this trouble?
Good question.
Do you have any idea why I
went to all this trouble?
Because I wanted to find out
the dependence of this
expression.
Wanda is telling me.
I'm translating as I go.
She's telling me in Romanian.
I want to find what this
maximization depends on with
respect these vectors, the
x, the sample vectors.
And what I've discovered is that
the optimization depends
only on the dot product
of pairs of samples.
And that's something we
want to keep in mind.
That's why I put it
in royal purple.
Now, up here, so let's see.
What do we call that
one up there?
That's two.
I guess, we'll call this
piece here three.
This piece here is four.
And now, there's
one more piece.
Because I want to take that w,
and not only stick it back
into that Lagrangian, I want
to stick it back into the
decision rule.
So now, my decision rule with
this expression for w is going
to be w plugged into
that thing.
So the decision rule is going to
look like the sum of alpha
i times y sub i times x sub
i dotted with the unknown
vector, like so.
And we're going to,
I guess, add b.
And we're going to say, if
that's greater than or equal
to 0, then plus.
So you see why the math is
beginning to sing to us now.
Because now, we discover that
the decision rule, also,
depends only on the dot product
of those sample
vectors and the unknown.
So the total of dependence
of all of the
math on the dot products.
All right.
And now, I hear a whisper.
Someone is saying, I
don't believe that
mathematicians can do it.
I don't think those numerical
analysts can find the
optimization.
I want to be sure of it.
Give me ocular proof.
So I'd like to run a
demonstration of it.
OK.
There's our sample problem.
The one I started the
hour out with.
Now, if the optimization
algorithm doesn't get stuck in
a local maximum or something,
it should find a nice,
straight line separating those
two guys to finding the widest
street between the minuses
and the pluses.
So in just a couple of steps,
you can see down
there in step 11.
It's decided that it's done
as much as it can on the
optimization.
And it's got three alphas.
And you can see that the two
negative samples both figure
into the solution, the weights
on the Lagrangian multipliers
are given by those little
yellow bars.
So the two negatives participate
in the solution as
one of the positives, but the
other positive doesn't.
So it has a 0 weight.
So everything worked out well.
Now, I said, as long as it
doesn't get stuck on a local
maximum, guess what, those
mathematical friends of ours
can tell us and prove
to us that this
thing is a convex space.
That means it can never get
stuck in a local maximum.
So in contrast with things like
neural nets, where you
have a plague of local maxima,
this guy never gets stuck in a
local maxima.
Let's try some other examples.
Here's two vertical points--
no surprises there, right?
Well, you say, well,
maybe it can't deal
with diagonal points.
Sure it can.
How about this thing here?
Yeah, it only needed two of the
points since any two, a
plus or minus, will
define the street.
Let's try this guy.
Oh.
What do you think?
What happened here?
Well, we're screwed, right?
Because it's linearly
inseparable--
bad news.
So in situations where it's
linearly inseparable, the
mechanism struggles, and
eventually, it will just slow
down and you truncate
it, because it's
not making any progress.
And you see the red dots there
are ones that it got wrong.
So you say, well, too bad for
our side-- doesn't look like
it's all that good anyway.
But then, a powerful idea comes
to the rescue, when
stuck switch to another
perspective.
So if we don't like the space
that we're in, because it
gives examples that are not
linearly separable, then we
can say, oh, shoot.
Here's our space.
Here are two points.
Here are two other points.
We can't separate them.
But if we could somehow get them
into another space, maybe
we can separate them, because
they look like this in the
other space, and they're
easy to separate.
So what we need, then, is a
transformation that will take
us from the space we're in into
a space where things are
more convenient, so we're
going to call that
transformation phi
with a vector, x.
That's the transformation.
And now, here's the reason
for all the magic.
I said, that the maximization
only depends on dot products.
So all I need to do the
maximization is the
transformation of one vector
dotted with the transformation
of another vector, like so.
That's what I need to maximize,
or to find the
maximum on.
Then, in order to recognize--
where did it go?
Underneath the chalkboard.
Oh, yes.
Here it is.
To recognize, all I need
is dot products, too.
So for that one I need phi of
x dotted with phi of u.
And just to make this a little
bit more consistent, the
notation, I'll call that
x j and this x sub i.
And that's x sub i.
Those are the quantities I
need in order to do it.
So that means that if I have a
function, let's call it k of x
sub i and x sub j, that's equal
to phi of x sub i dotted
with phi of x sub j.
Then, I'm done.
This is what I need.
I don't actually need this.
All I need is that function, k,
which happens to be called
a kernel function, which
provides me with the dot
product of those two vectors
in another space.
I don't have to know
the transformation
into the other space.
And that's the reason that
this stuff is a miracle.
So what are some of the kernels
that are popular?
One is the linear kernel that
says that u dotted with v plus
1 to the n-th is such a kernel,
because it's got u in
it and v in it, the
two vectors.
And this is what the dot product
is in the other space.
So that's one choice.
Another choice is a kernel
that looks like
this, e to the minus.
Let's take the dot product
of the difference
of those two guys.
Let's take the magnitude
of that and
divide it by some sigma.
That's a second kind of kernel
that we can use.
So let's go back and see if we
can solve this problem by
transforming it into another
space where we have another
perspective.
So that's it.
That's another kernel.
And so sure, we can.
And that's the answer when
transformed back into the
original space.
We can also try doing that
with a so-called
radial basis kernel.
That's the one with the
exponential in it.
We can learn on that one.
Boom.
No problem.
So we've got a general method
that's convex and guaranteed
to produce a global solution.
We've got a mechanism that
easily allows us to transform
this into another space.
So it works like a charm.
Of course, it doesn't remove
all possible problems.
Look at that exponential
thing here.
If we choose a sigma that is
small enough, then those
sigmas are essentially shrunk
right around the sample
points, and we could
get overfitting.
So it doesn't immunize us
against overfitting, but it
does immunize us against local
maxima and does provide us
with a general mechanism for
doing a transformation into
another space with a
better perspective.
Now, the history lesson, all
this stuff feels fairly new.
It feels like it's younger
than you are.
Here's the history of it.
Vapnik immigrated from the
Soviet Union to the United
States in about 1991.
Nobody ever heard of this stuff
before he immigrated.
He actually had done this work
on the basic support vector
idea in his Ph.D. thesis
at Moscow University
in the early '60s.
But it wasn't possible for him
to do anything with it,
because they didn't have any
computers they could try
anything out with.
So he spent the next 25 years at
some oncology institute in
the Soviet Union doing
applications.
Somebody from Bell Labs
discovers him, invites him
over to the United States
where, subsequently, he
decides to immigrate.
In 1992, or thereabouts, Vapnik
submits three papers to
NIPS, the Neural Information
Processing Systems journal.
All of them were rejected.
He's still sore about it,
but it's motivating.
So around 1992, 1993, Bell
Labs was interested in
hand-written character
recognition
and in neural nets.
Vapnik thinks that
neural nets--
what would be a good
word to use?
I can think of the vernacular,
but he thinks that
they're not very good.
So he bets a colleague a good
dinner that support vector
machines will eventually do
better at handwriting
recognition then neural nets.
And it's a dinner bet, right?
It's not that big of deal.
But as Napoleon said, it's
amazing what a soldier will do
for a bit of ribbon.
So that makes colleague, who's
working on this problem with
handwritten recognition, decides
to try a support
vector machine with a kernel,
in which n equals 2, just
slightly nonlinear, works
like a charm.
Was this the first time anybody
tried a kernel?
Vapnik actually had the idea in
his thesis but never though
it was very important.
As soon as it was shown to work
in the early '90s on the
problem handwriting recognition,
Vapnik
resuscitated the idea of the
kernel, began to develop it,
and became an essential part of
the whole approach of using
support vector machines.
So the main point about this
is that it was 30 years in
between the concept and anybody
ever hearing about it.
It was 30 years between Vapnik's
understanding of
kernels and his appreciation
of their importance.
And that's the way things often
go, great ideas followed
by long periods of nothing
happening, followed by an
epiphanous moment when the
original idea seemed to have
great power with just a
little bit of a twist.
And then, the world
never looks back.
And Vapnik, who nobody ever
heard of until the early '90s,
becomes famous for something
that everybody knows about
today who does machine
learning.